Різдвяно-новорічний гармидер - уже позаду.
Марі Франке із західнонімецького Мюнстера
хоче в новому році зробити велике прибирання.
Під гаслом: все старе – геть!
Адже прибирання може приносити задоволення.
Ось тільки цьому треба трохи повчитися.
На мою думку, в мене немає системи,
ось у чому велика проблема. Я просто перекидає зліва направо,
але нічого не викидаю.
І ось тут якраз потрібна професійна допомога.
Деніз Когон - консультантка з прибирання.
Вже сім років її знають
як "фройляйн Орднунг".
За 60 євро на годину вона допомагає людям
відновити лад у квартирі
або й у житті.
Це найбільш хаотична кімната.
Сюди складається все, що зайве,
і письмовий стіл постійно завалений.
Ця шафа була якимось крайнім рішенням.“
„У людей надто багато речей,
вони не мають структури та зовсім не обмірковують,
куди покласти речі або як їх розсортувати.
Є багато маленьких прийомчиків, які можуть зарадити.“
Куточки із накопиченим мотлохом – хто їх не знає?
"Пані Порядок" демонструє, як і з чого почати.
Знаючи три основних правила,
впоратися може кожен. Правило номер один:
Відбраковувати непотрібне! Усе, що більше не використовується, слід негайно викинути.
До побачення! Саме так – у смітник.
Непросто, оскільки у кожній маленькій коробці
– свій власний хаос.
Ось це, мені видається, можна у сміття разом зі старими речами.
Головна складність – вирішити, що треба викинути,
а що залишити. Допомогти у виборі може гасло:
"Залишайте лише те,
що любите і – що справді необхідне".
Ми просто кладемо усе,
що тобі справді потрібне, на цей стіл.
Непотрібного баласту - позбулися.
Час для правила номер два:
Вдумливо знову розкласти все по полицях.
Це означає - речі, які потрібні щодня,
справді мусять бути під рукою. Аби можна
було одразу відшукати необхідне, щоб ви знали,
куди саме поклали речі.
У прибиранні кожна річ потребує
свого постійного місця.
Для письмового столу головне:
„Загальне правило для робочого місця:
не більше трьох поточних проектів на столі,
щоб не загубитися у мотлосі.“
Новий порядок позначається, у тому числі, на самопочутті.
Порядок приносить спокій у дім.
Можна набагато краще розслабитися, якщо стіл прибраний,
якщо речі не лежать на підлозі.
Це полегшує життя.“
Справді: робоча кімната справляє одразу зовсім
інше враження.
„Якось раптово з‘явилося відлуння. Стільки місця і усе таке чисте.
Кімната наче стала більшою."
Але увага:
хто вважає, що прибирання завершене, той помиляється.
Час для правила номер три.
„Це безперервний процес. Треба завжди
залишатися у грі. Дещо уникнути цього
дозволить запровадження правила
«плюс один – мінус один». Тобто, якщо одна річ додається у дім,
то слід продумати, яку річ натомість буде прибрано
з дому.“
Отож, порядок потрібно планувати!
Відбраковувати, викидати й упорядковувати
все заново. На перший погляд, банально
і просто. Та у багатьох людей
нічого не виходить.
„Я вважаю, що без Деніз позбулася б меншої кількості речей,
і це мені далося б набагато важче. А так все було нормально
і мені не довелося довго роздумувати.
"Швидко геть! геть! геть!“ Фахова підтримка - цілком доречна.“
У прибраній квартирі зрештою легше працювати й жити.
Утім, при всіх перевагах
порядку, це все-таки, за німецьким прислів‘ям,
лише "половина життя".